over the course of the last two months
balance streamer jason r has been
accused of dodging ranked games with
women muting women in his rank games and
being misogynistic towards women in the
valrant community these accusations
which were originally levied against him
back in february have since been argued
about and discussed across twitch and
social media ad nauseam but they
recently blew up once again when him and
mega streamer tarik had an almost
hour-long argument on stream about the
subject in front of 20 000 people on
saturday night
here's the whole story
now while the situation boiled over in a
very public way this past weekend in
order to properly understand what's been
going on with jason r we need to go back
in time to february on february 20th
this tweet from shopify rebellion
valorem player panini that read when are
we going to talk about that one big
streamer that mutes every girl in his
ranked games garnered a lot of attention
and reaction from both men and women in
the tack fps scene while the original
tweet obviously did not name anyone
specifically many of the replies and
quote tweets reference jason r as the
tweets rolled in on february 21st jason
r was accused of intentionally muting
women on his team and ranked
intentionally dodging ranked games when
he had women on his team pretending his
game crashed when he had women on his
team and generally being misogynistic
towards women in history included in the
accusations being waged against him were
two clips that were
four or more years old one in which he
refers to women on twitch as hoes and
the other one involving his wife himself
and a woman in his twitch chat both of
which he has since said were taken out
of context now of course that's a long
list of allegations but the general
sentiment is that jason r did not want
to play with women on his team
or at the very least communicate with
them sentinel's igl shazam also
corroborated some of these allegations
on stream that day when his chat asked
him about the situation shazam even
claimed that jason dodged a game shazam
was playing with his girlfriend junah
and claimed his game crashed he just
instimutes any girl that's on his team
and ranked or he dodges the game if
there's a girl on his team
that's not talking [ __ ]
i'm just saying
that is weird behavior to me that's not
okay now in response to these
accusations back in february he made a
few comments on stream like this one
where he referred to women as [ __ ]
which was called out on twitter by
dignitas valor and player reign dodge it
can't dodge anymore man lord knows there
might be a [ __ ] girl on my team
lord knows might be a [ __ ] [ __ ] on
the squad might get hated for the rest
of my life and it's important to note
that before i go any further in this
story jason originally denied the
allegations that he was dodging games he
said that he uses a pretty complicated
dual pc setup to stream and that his
game crash is pretty frequently and that
led to the perceived dodging not only am
i on a dual pc stream i'm using voice
meter banana
when my game my game will sometimes load
into the game it'll sit on a loading
screen i don't even hear anybody talking
i don't know who's in my game at all my
game will crash i don't dodge anybody i
don't do any of that [ __ ] and then as
the situation started to gain more
attention he made these comments the
next day on february 23rd
stop disrespecting women how do i
disrespect women i don't talk to them
how do i disrespect women sorry i didn't
know that not interacting
with them is disrespecting them and then
the next day on february 24th the
majority of the discussion about jason
the allegations and the back and forth
between him and other streamers all
culminated in an eight-minute statement
he made before his stream and posted to
his youtube channel here's my statement
you ready because it's only stuff i've
repeated repeatedly said over and over
but here it is again for the people in
the back
in this statement he addressed the
accusations and said he is not a
misogynist and does not want to spread
hate he also said that the accusations
of him dodging tarik's ten man and
dodging shazam and his girlfriend's game
because of the inclusion of women were
being presented in a misleading way he
also went on to claim that some of the
people leveling these accusations were
using their platform to create a
tremendous amount of hate towards his
wife out of anger that she may be
controlling his every move on the
internet end quote this last point was
in reference to some of the original
accusations that the reason he dodges
ranked games with women is because of
his relationship with his wife now it's
also important to note that there were
prominent voices that came out in
defense of jason r in this situation cs
go streamer mo in particular who has
streamed with jason r for years said
that this is just a matter of him
respecting his wife okay so that was
february jason was accused jason
responded multiple times he eventually
made a statement at the end
and then things settled down
for the most part that is until this
past weekend where jason said this about
balance streamer and exius gopro tarik
tarik the [ __ ] is fake as f he's
met my wife i've met his girl i've met
him in real life [ __ ] literally
has the audacity to ban my name in this
[ __ ] chat
because he's too cuz he's a because he
changed up he's so [ __ ] because he's
he's finally got [ __ ] views and
that's all he cares about now for those
uninitiated tarik is one of the biggest
fps streamers on twitch right now he is
obviously an integral part of the c9 cs
go major win and he has become a very
important part of bridging the gap from
cs to valerie he routinely hosts watch
parties for vct matches that have
50 000 plus viewers and well
since back in the cs go days tarik and
jason r have run in the same crowd of
tack fps minded north american streamers
and so after a month of this going down
jason r vented the other night about how
tarik had not come to his defense in the
situation especially as somebody who
knew him personally and had met his wife
tarik had also blocked the word jason r
in his twitch chat and so after jason
called tarek an l friend in game taric
invited him into his valerian party to
settle the situation once and for all
let's [ __ ] get to the bottom of this
okay well hold on hold on i want you to
be here for this this all went down
after midnight on sunday morning eastern
time
with more than 20 000 people watching in
taric street and over the course of the
next better part of an hour
they argued mostly about how jason felt
that because tarik knew him and his wife
personally and had spent time with them
he should have come to his defense and
told everyone that he wasn't a
misogynist jason also repeatedly
suggested that the reason tarik didn't
come forward in the first place was that
he was growing on twitch and he didn't
want to risk his success you were in a
position
where
you have but you have met both me and
stephanie you were in a position to tell
people yo
jason r is not the [ __ ] person that
these [ __ ] people are trying to label
him as you have defended and shut down
certain people and banned certain people
but you have not gone out and told
people and actually gave people a
character can witness of me all these
people who are saying things that
character witnesses what whether not
misogynist but you you chose to be a
[ __ ] [ __ ] girl about it and just
wouldn't can say [ __ ] to me i think we
could say that's a pretty rough choice
of words given the situation now to this
tarek responded multiple times that yes
despite the fact that he spent time with
jason and with jason's wife in person he
believes that there is quote undeniable
and undisputable evidence that jason r
dodges ranked games with women yes i've
hung out with you and your girlfriend
sure but it doesn't take away from the
fact that there's undeniable
undisputable evidence that you clearly
dodge queues versus girls if i play with
you then it seems like i support that
behavior and i don't i don't know why
you do it it's your personal reason it's
your private matter but i don't agree
with it okay jason let's hear from you
why do you dodge girls and queues then
tell them tell us right now why are you
dodging these games yes tell us let's
respect my relationship with my wife
enough to not allow people to start
flipping out of that i'm just playing
with another
girl now obviously i can't show you all
45 minutes of this conversation
but the back and forth was mostly that
the whole time jason thought tarik was
being a bad friend for not defending him
and taric maintained that he would have
defended him if he agreed with him and
felt like he was being unfairly targeted
and as you might imagine the next day
all hell broke loose all over social
media streamers like xqc ludwig and qt
cinderella were all reacting to the
conversation on stream and it once again
became the talk of the valent world this
led jason r to once again address these
allegations on stream only this time he
admitted to dodging games with women
everyone wants him to say he purposely
dodges just say it i have
i have said that dude
again i will say it again for the people
in the back
i
dodged certain situations
for my wife and my relationship from now
on
i will not be dodging or moving
or avoiding
these situations
from now on
and i'm sorry
like
again
i didn't mean
any harm
he also released this statement to
twitter entitled it taking
accountability quote i was avoiding
certain online situations out of respect
from my wife stephanie when i was
younger i was not a good person to her
and i take accountability for my actions
that led us to this place i was trying
to avoid potentially toxic situations
not wanting her to be put through drama
i will no longer be avoiding these
online situations and i am sorry that my
intentions were misconstrued by my
actions there are so many lies about me
out there lies about steph who doesn't
deserve this there are people making
false allegations off of out of context
information i wish nothing but peace and
love for people and ask for a touch of
understanding i am sorry end quote and
that statement brings us to more or less
where we are today after over a month of
back and forth jason admitted that with
the intention of respecting his wife he
was avoiding these online situations and
as far as the public arbitration of this
situation goes that's pretty much where
this all ends i think it's pretty safe
to say that this situation is very
complicated and has shed a lot of light
on the difficulties associated with
being a woman in the gaming and esports
world and in having your personal life
wrapped up in your streaming life that
said the fact is that dozens of
prominent voices people who have the
safety of a platform to come forward
have been made to feel uncomfortable by
jason's actions and whether you think
what he did is super severe or not
that is a problem full stop everybody
should feel safe playing video games on
the internet i don't think that's up for
debate and hopefully after a month of
this all being put out there in public
jason releasing his statement
apologizing and admitting to some of the
accusations we've arrived at the end of
this with some shred of agreement now on
the other side of things assuming the
death threats and vitriol that jason
says are being thrown at him are also
real i think we can all agree that
that's a pretty [ __ ] up way to handle
this situation hopefully we've reached
the conclusion of this situation we can
all take the lessons we've learned and
try to be better tomorrow because of it
you